pereus that's me mhm that's who you're
named after because he was a hero
because he was Brave and kind and
Against All Odds he managed to find his
way to a happy
ending I'm used to the world feeling
weird to
me like a puzzle with half their own
pieces but lately it all feels different
somehow Percy you are special when
you're ready to hear what the gods have
in store for you they'll tell you Percy
the stories I have told you about great
Gods and
Monsters they are
real this is crazy you are a half blood
and half Bloods are not safe in the
world everything has been training for
what's still ahead of
you hold on
[Music]
Percy Jackson your father needs your
help the master BS has been stolen if
you don't return the boat there will be
war
that is your
quest I know it sounds
daunting but you won't be alone a quest
is always undertaken by three demig Gods
process reality differently we got to
figure out what you're good
at should I try again no
no there's no place for me
here you still don't get where you fit
into all
this we were sent on a quest by the gods
what you think it would be easy demig
Gods
welcome I'm not leaving you perus hold
fast Brave the
store maybe I won't even need a
[Music]
sword I'm going to need a
sword